tremendous
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be
alive uncle Joey's back [ __ ] back
slingin dick giving out oatmeal [ __ ]
Halloween you know you know how we're
doing it
[ __ ] Hilary got more felonies than me
what he gonna do but who gives a [ __ ]
who Joey's here it's Monday October 31st
Halloween or Souls Day tomorrow or Saint
day after that we got three [ __ ] days
of heat [ __ ] but never fear Uncle
Joe is here today 11 o'clock Joe Rogan
experience [ __ ] that's how we do
it it's been a long time since we rock
and roll it's [ __ ] time tonight the
Church of what's happening [ __ ] it now
you understand me we're gonna get down
and dirty and that's it you got the week
by the [ __ ] balls all you need is you
tonight you'll probably be out look at
me I'm Frankenstein who gives a [ __ ] if
you're above [ __ ] 21 stay on mind
your business get your dick sucked with
a [ __ ] propeller right yeah that
that's Halloween why [ __ ] come from
all right but Joey enough with the
chitty-chat what are you smoking today
all oh we got this hardcore perennial
and we got the tail ended up a [ __ ] oh
oh Jesus I feel good Vegas was great I
saw some great people Scott Ross got
theta Z me my main man talking land his
little son for his [ __ ] birthday and
that's it yeah I'm saying it was a nice
D [ __ ] week and now I'm back I got my
[ __ ] kid chocolate shirt on today
from a van Eyck you but what what sucka
I missed you guys it's been a few days
in Vegas they got cameras everywhere
I can periscope live I'm saying you
could catch me just turn on your [ __ ]
computer sir there's no challenge there
I want to take a few days off give you a
few days off and now I'm back [ __ ] I'm
not gonna judge it to today what the
[ __ ] JRE but I'll be in to G to
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday and [ __ ]
Saturday and Sunday I'm back [ __ ] my
backs
my back's okay but how long can you
[ __ ] cry for hit I'm saying you can't
cry forever
yeah I can't stop the bleed from time no
there's no [ __ ] bleeding with my
world we got to keep doing what we do I
decide that I feel good I'm LT I love my
family I love you [ __ ] and
that's it what else can we [ __ ] ask
for
we got reefer we got love and we got the
number one thing that you need [ __ ]
hope and balls you understand me
when you got balls you got no you need
no [ __ ] hope it's all about boss
they're a Monday you got that's it
tomorrow star scene turkeys and [ __ ]
pilgrims and people family the holidays
are here you sit there going what I'm
gonna do my [ __ ] life well it's time
talk something grab your balls get the
[ __ ] dart gun and it's time to go out
there and rob somebody put it [ __ ]
together I've been telling you this for
[ __ ] monsters here flies you didn't
call you didn't do this you didn't do it
man you're sitting there like a [ __ ]
bah-bah-bah thinkin to myself what's
gonna happen with my life I told you
smoke from Reaper make your goals go
down the [ __ ] list
they can't stop you you put your balls
where your [ __ ] heart is and that's
it oh yeah see cause as I said it
but Joey enough is enough we gonna smoke
a bowl that perennial I never thought
you asked
[Laughter]
look a dream of my daughter this
afternoon maybe a [ __ ] cowboy I'll
take pictures you know my periscope with
the [ __ ] cowboy for you people I'll
never let you down and beside that it's
a ho-hum dad write the book you know the
special comes out December 8th I've been
[ __ ] Boston November 11 Foxwood
casino I'm the [ __ ] 12th at 7:00
[ __ ] 30 you better be there or
be square
let's try this perennial Joey what's
with the chitter chatter Joe you know
spark that's [ __ ] perennial what
that's [ __ ] Vegas a out of your lungs
am but anyway I love you [ __ ]
were on my heart I miss you I sincerely
[ __ ] missed you you know I love you
listen without you I got much you guys
know that when I you I'm too small these
[ __ ] steps with you they can't stop
us we're going on the China we're gonna
[ __ ] Peru we're doing everything but
when I yeah I'm just a regular ho-hum
[ __ ] half a fact that's it I need you
[ __ ] and you need me together
I smoke dope but should we crack a
little [ __ ] jokes you know the whole
thing and at the end of the day guess
what unlike these are the [ __ ]
[ __ ] that you see that he's cool
he's got a tattoo of a burner listen and
I'm nothing but [ __ ] dick and hard
for you understand me
dick and [ __ ] hard which is what you
want from a friend
oh I love it look at me I'm surrounded
I'm like a [ __ ] I'm like a spirit I'm
the ball story for do you thing all
right you know I love you [ __ ]
well my heart you wrote your goals down
you squeeze your balls you pouted your
nuts and now you're going out there on
Monday proving to yourself that you
could do anything and we'll all these
people on the show laughter they got a
pre is to show their friends I care and
listen the only person you got to prove
anything to is T you [ __ ] that's
the heart that's my heart is credit is
the guy that lives behind my [ __ ]
heart call me a fat [ __ ] loser [ __ ]
[ __ ] all day so at the end that
they don't worry about them you got
impress yourself [ __ ] there's the
one ball ball in fact this [ __ ]
finished kaput I'll be at the weed store
at 10:01 and then I'll shoot straight to
[ __ ] Joe's that's how I roll you in
the same
and that's it who loves you more than me
nobody listen holidays are coming it's
not about money it's about love and
being there for the [ __ ] people in
your family don't ever get confused
don't let that make you [ __ ] feel bad
but you gotta show up with an envelope a
box of chalk we had to do something so
get up get out and that's it [ __ ]
I love you [ __ ] see you tonight
at eight o'clock see you this morning at
11 you know you got me all [ __ ] day
okay
pretty much I'm stalling till he kills
and we'll continue this little chitchat
[ __ ] latest a plaque I have a
phenomenal day uncle Joey loves you
[ __ ]